BRIAN:  LISTEN UP A MISSOURI
BUSINESS OWNER IS GETTING
CREATIVE AFTER SHUTDOWN FOR
REFUSING TO ENFORCE MASK
MANDATES AMANDA WALLACE,
REOPENING HER RESTAURANT AS A "
PRIVATE CLUB" TO AVOID THE
COVID PROTOCOLS PUT ON
RESTAURANTS IN THAT STATE AND
NOW, THE COUNTY IS STILL
ATTEMPTING SHUT THE BUSINESS
DOWN VIA A COURT ORDER.
AMANDA WALLACE JOINS US.
AMANDA WHAT BROUGHT YOU TO THIS
POINT?
>> JUST TO KEEP MY BUSINESS
OPEN.
BRIAN:  SO IN ORDER TO AVOID THE
MASK MANDATE, YOU HAVE 90%
OF YOUR STAFF VACCINATED.
YOU SAID WHAT?
YOU SAID WHAT WERE YOU GOING TO
DO?
>> WE WERE COMPLETELY COMPLYING
AT THAT POINT, AND I STILL GOT
SHUTDOWN, SO WE TURNED INTO A
PRIVATE CLUB AND WE’RE NOT OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC.
BRIAN:  SO NOW YOU CHARGE A
MEMBERSHIP FEE?
>> YEAH, $1 MEMBERSHIP.
BRIAN:  SO I BECOME A MEMBER DO
I GET A CARD?
>> YOU WILL GET A CARD.
YOU JUST SIGN IN, PAY YOUR
DOLLAR, AND YOU’RE IN THE CLUB.
BRIAN:  THEREFORE, YOU AVOID
WHAT THE COUNTY’S TRYING TO DO,
CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
BRIAN:  SO WHERE DO YOU STAND
RIGHT NOW?
>> I’M JUST WAITING, HONESTLY.
I DON’T KNOW WHERE I STAND.
I’M WAITING.
BRIAN:  BUT DO YOU HAVE LUNCH
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU SERVING LUNCH
TODAY, BREAKFAST?
>> YES, WE’RE OPEN 8:00-2:00.
BRIAN:  I ADMIRE YOU BEING
CREATIVE.
HERE IS WHAT THE COUNTY SAID.
DESPITE NUMEROUS WARNINGS AND
ATTEMPTS BY THE COUNTY, SHE HAS
REFUSED TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION AND HAS MADE IT CLEAR SHE
HAS NO PLANS TO DO SO THAT’S WHY
FOR THE FIRST TIME DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE COUNTY WILL BE
SEEKING A COURT ORDER TO CLOSE
THE BUSINESS.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> THIS HAPPENED WITHIN ONE
WEEK.
START TO FINISH.
THE FINES, THE TICKETS, THAT’S
RIDICULOUS.
OVER A MASK.
THAT’S NOT A MANDATE IS NOT A
LAW.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING.
BRIAN:  AND YOUR CUSTOMERS KNOW
THE RISK?
THEY ARE VACCINATED, NOT
VACCINATED, YOU DON’T WANT TO
ASK THEM, THEY DON’T TELL YOU,
THE CUSTOMERS COMPLAINING?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
THE CUSTOMERS HAVE NOTHING BUT
SUPPORT AND LOVE AND ITS BEEN
AMAZING.
BRIAN:  HAS YOUR LAWYER
CONSULTED YOU TO GO PRIVATE LIKE
THIS?
>> I DO HAVE LEGAL ASSISTANCE,
YES.
BRIAN:  DO YOU BELIEVE YOU’RE
LEGALLY PROTECTED?
>> YES.
BRIAN:  NICE.
AMANDA I HOPE YOU WIN.
I REALLY, I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS
TO GET A RESTAURANT GOING.
RAE’S CAFE CHECK IT OUT BECOME
A MEMBER FOR $1.